Philippe Vigier merci d'être là vous
êtes député MoDem vous êtes en charge de
votre des retraites pour votre partie
pardon alors je voudrais reprendre le
titre du Parisien hier François Bayrou
fait encore entendre sa petite musique
sur les retraites c'est vrai que à
l'heure de la présentation du projet par
la première ministre l'exécutif attend
une majorité dans les rangs et à fond
derrière lui et pourtant François Bayrou
dit que cette améliorable cette réforme
des retraites sur les ondes radio
évidemment c'est un mot améliorable qui
a une portée particulière ça veut dire
quoi sur le fond sur la forme le message
d'abord bonjour améliorable je vous
rappelle que vous soyez où avait été le
premier à demander dès le mois de
novembre qui est plus de temps plus de
temps pour expliquer aux Français on
fait pas une réforme de retraite comme
ça pour faire une réforme de retraite ou
parce que on a écrit dans une campagne
présidentielle on l'a fait parce que il
s'agit de solidifier ce système de
retraite
de manière à ce que les petites
retraites ont pu apporter une réponse et
vu que dans le texte est prévu
salariés qui ont 850 euros s'ils ont une
carrière pleine auront 1200 euros on
fait une réforme pour améliorer la
pénibilité c'est indispensable on file
réforme parce qu'il a des déficits
publics considérables et donc lorsqu'on
dit que c'est améliorable c'est que dans
le sens de la pédagogie en cas de choses
qu'on peut améliorer par exemple nous
proposons qu'il y ait en 2027 un
rendez-vous on en est où sur cette
réforme qui ont été vue une clause de
revoyure pour voir si les mesures que
nous avons prises sont efficaces elles
sont suffisamment efficaces si par
exemple l'affaire de l'emploi des
seniors nous sommes derniers de la
classe de toute l'Europe et ce qu'on va
se donner les moyens de faire en sorte
que plus de seigneurs qui traversent qui
travaillent dans l'entreprise donc
lorsqu'il dit cela c'est qu'il faut être
aussi attentif parce qu'on voit bien
qu'il y a de la mobilisation donc ça
veut dire aussi qu'il y a eu un déficit
de pédagogie et nous continuons ce
travail de pédagogie
plus loin il a eu le temps qui voulait
en souviens aussi de ce dîner où il
avait insisté auprès d'Emmanuel Macron
en disant ça ne peut pas être dans le
projet de loi sur la sécurité sociale
avec un 49-3 à la clé il avait été
entendu donc François Bayrou a été quand
même entendu le modem aussi sur pas mal
de points est-ce qu'on peut pas se dire
qu'à l'heure où vous jugez tous ensemble
à l'exécutif que cette réforme est
nécessaire il vaut mieux un texte
imparfait défendu par tous plutôt que de
pinailler pardonnez-moi l'expression sur
certains certaines choses
que les républicains demandaient
exactement la même chose de faire en
sorte que sur les petites retraites
j'insiste
un problème de position de majorité
d'abord toute la campagne présidentielle
je vous rappelle qu'ils avaient dit quoi
retraite à 65 ans donc lorsque nous
proposons est beaucoup plus semble-t-il
en phase avec ce que peuvent accepter
les Françaises et les Français vous
savez il y a quelque chose qui me frappe
toujours les jeunes générations n'ont
pas confiance au système de retraite
donc on a certainement mal expliqué les
choses pourquoi justement il y avait
cette fragilité donc c'est pas pédalier
c'est au contraire faire en sorte que
cette réforme indispensable puisse se
réaliser et c'est ça que nous voulons
c'est parce que il s'agit pas de bloquer
le pays justement en se mettant à
l'écoute de ce qui a été dit par les uns
par les autres en voyant les partisans
sociaux il y a eu lundi nous avons fait
un séminaire sur la retraite avec les
collègues du groupe centriste donc des
démocrates à l'Assemblée on a bien vu
qu'il y a des choses sur lesquelles on
pouvait encore avancer par exemple vous
savez que lorsque vous avez une carrière
hachée une cari arrachée suite à un
accident
maladie non vous pouvez avoir tout votre
email vous pouvez avoir tout votre email
mais vous attendez 67 ans pour avoir une
retraite à taux plein on souhaiterait
qu'il y ait une prise en compte de
manière à ce que et bien quelqu'un
puisse partir lorsqu'il a déjà eu un
drame dans sa vie j'entends quelque
chose je dis absolument pas le contraire
je vous parle juste du tempo est-ce que
au moment où la première ministre
présente le projet au moment où on sent
que les syndicats fourbissent leurs
armes il n'est pas l'heure là maintenant
de faire front uni puisque cette réforme
vous la voulez et puis d'attendre les
amendements et les discussions
rassurez-vous nous confront Unis parce
que nous voulons que cette réforme soit
réussie mais c'est pas pour autant que
on n'a pas encore des améliorations
qu'on va porter d'ailleurs c'est le
temps parlementaire qui arrive
maintenant c'est à l'Assemblée ça sera
aussi dans ensuite de ce que nous ont là
c'est pas une surprise on a parlé à la
première ministre qui est d'ailleurs
c'est montrer très à l'écoute puis j'ai
cru comprendre que plus d'un de la
République avait dit à ses ministres en
conseil des ministres qu'il fallait
extrêmement attentif et vigilant sur un
certain nombre de points donc vous voyez
peut-être l'expérience de François
Bayrou dans la vie politique depuis
quelques années et bien chacun comprend
qu'elle était utile alors certains
marcheurs disent précisément que
François Bayrou ne sera jamais content
sur sur cette réforme parce qu'il aurait
voulu la mener lui-même en tant que
Premier ministre
des petites explications entre amis
c'est pas le sujet vous savez j'ai
observé
reprend ils veulent plus les petites
retraites du groupe Renaissance et
partir des amendements vous serez à
partir du même message que celui que
nous avons porté donc s'agit pas
d'opposer les uns et les autres c'est de
trouver les solutions de passage pour
que on réussisse cette réforme et la
réforme des régimes spéciaux ça n'est
pas rien mais pour qu'elle pardonnez-moi
Philippe vivier pour qu'elle réussisse
cette réforme il faut qu'elle passe
auprès des Français s'il y a des mois de
blocage dans le pays elle exécutif fera
à un moment donné marche arrière comme
ça déjà été le Cameroun toutefois avec
d'autres avec d'autres gouvernants donc
comment faire à part montrer un fondu
ne soit pas totalement unie là
maintenant à ce moment clé du message
donné aux Français
un peu plus pour arriver en 2027 à 63
ans pour la rue en 2032 à 64 ans on
s'est retrouvé aussi sur un message fort
l'aide-soignante moi je lui parle en
direct dans les yeux dans les yeux vous
ne partirez pas à 64 ans comme vous le
dit toute la journée dans tous les
médias c'est il y aura toujours une déco
pour les carrières longues qui ont
commencé à 18 ans vous partirez un
maximum à 62 ans c'est à dire 44 ans
donc tout ce que nous avons fait ces
dernières semaines tout ce que nous
ensembles horizons ce qu'on fait le
groupe républicains qui veulent avancer
il y a les autres qui veulent rien faire
vous savez les socialistes c'est eux qui
ont fait voter la réforme Touraine et à
l'heure actuelle là je les gaz c'est
combien c'est 62 ans donc quelques
années plus tard ils vont dire écoutez
on a fait n'importe quoi avec les
Français pas du tout nous ne voulons que
cette réforme passe qu'elle soit encore
plus justes qu'elle soit encore plus
comprise c'est le sens de la pédagogique
n'y voyez pas des germes de division
vous voyez simplement le fait qu'on veut
réussir très rapidement parce qu'il ne
reste peu de temps François Bayrou
aimerait aussi faire une idée c'est de
taxer davantage les entreprises en
augmentant la part de cotisations
patronales c'est refus net éclair de
l'exécutif là-dessus vous comprenez
qu'en période de crise de hausse des
coûts de l'énergie etc d'entreprises en
difficulté à cause de ça ça ne soit pas
encada
cette propositions dans laquelle on peut
discuter nous allions faire les pompiers
alternatives de financement parce que
c'est bien beau de parler d'avancer et
il les faut il faut aussi trouver des
modalités de financement mais c'était
cette proposition qu'il a faite faisait
partie d'un ensemble de pistes de
financement que nous avions mis sur la
table et donc elle n'a pas été retenu
elle a été retenue à la marche je vous
rappelle quand même au 01
0,1% du cotisations patronales compensé
par Jackson du travail qui baissera
parce que vous voyez je termine
là-dessus sur les seniors les taux
d'accident du travail nous souhaitons
qu'il baisse je ne peux pas me
satisfaire d'un pays dans lequel 40% des
seigneurs uniquement travaillent
lorsqu'ils ont 60 ans ça veut dire que
les autres font quoi ils sont en burn
out ils sont chez eux plusieurs parties
alors qu'il y a tant à transmettre aux
jeunes génération il faut être beaucoup
plus innovant sur le cube en retraite
donc bref soyons innovants et je suis
persuadé qu'on trouvera les voix merci
beaucoup